2021年世界はコロナウイルスの恐怖により
ホークの人々が恐怖に震えていた
俺もその一人だった
そう
北錦
クチンあれば
あったりとか
おっちゃんといえば
河野ない子
鋼牙のところに行けます
ああああああ
こばっ
高この
頭の頃
行動 o
どうぞ
その
[音楽]
この動画は良い
その後
いっ
goo
あああん
うわっには乗ってくれやっと待ってよ
ネットで見たんだけどはくちって
ほんまに大丈夫なのかコレ
聞いてみよう
どうぞ
終わってよ
いらっしゃいどうぞどうぞ
ゴンの改善
もういいからどうぞ the rush
あらず氏の彼方しておらず指導ようこそ改めましてこのへさせまして
光太郎大事です基本よろしくお願いします
大変超えてことは売れてると今日ですなぜ
おん
[音楽]
ちょっと緊張してますねパンガー県庁舎ですマップ陳佩
こんな奥手に通じてですね
僕メルユーチューバーと言いますネットの人間になる米方なんでしょ
テレビとかじゃないネットの部分の情報とは妻入ってきて何だか
誤っプチとか本当に枠線って大丈夫なのとか
きつなる出るのかん
いろいろ含めてのこの大臣にお聞きしたいことがありますではい
何でも聞いてください何でも聞いていい奴ら聞いてください
ほっぽい感じがありますよねナッツをして来ていいですか見てる方もワクチンどんな
感じなんだろうと思っている方がいらっしゃると思ってで目的なくて打たれたので
色々聞いていきます竜王
西きれずに逃げてきた人がいいありがとうございます
訪問の大臣からドリアンを頂いたぞ
これはドリアンにもいろんな種類があるんですけど
灰猫や
ね朝から回答して用意してありがとうございますあります
[音楽]
どうおいしいでもう一回行っちゃう
はい2
お仕事どうですか
学習が結構大変です大変ですはいもう
一人でも多くの
皆さんに一日も早く
特に菅総理気が短い人なんで
[音楽]
ブーブーそれくらいそっかじゃあもしですかああよね
けれども可能
[音楽]
つかの仏法を記事
日本の大臣はせ
伊那アイドルとは言えません
入るはい
子供の頃山口百恵と桜田淳子
した
当然ねちょっとで0障害障害のアイドル帰ったらチェックしてください
えっ本当に想定な疑問なんですけど
なぜワクチンで2回撃たなきゃいけないたぶん1回打ってこう体の中に免疫ができて
くる
それをもう1回打つことによって免疫が上がってくるんだと思う
ながら
あってもまったく効果がないわけではないんだけどもやっぱり3回家とその値がもっと
高くなるし
たぶん2回家とその効果が長く続く立
効き目な大きくなっ
そうですね河野大臣のご趣味は英
湘南ベルマーレの
感染ですもうで質問が入っ
ネットの噂で聞いたんですけどパクチーを言ったら
磁石がくっつくみたいな
なんでえっジャジャヴって何かで見た鮭れててっ西各地かないでしょ
そうですねこんなことがあるはずがないよねもう手間
以前の問題めっちゃ出されたなんかワクチン打ったら5人に繋がるって言うのも処分な
事項があるとかですよね
校閲アップサースバル家ですもうそれはちょっと
否定する前の電話以前の話だと思うんねさっき言ったらそうな風テレビな
あっ実際僕は5
売ったらいいですか7月末までに高齢者が終わると思います静岡市で埋葬するともう
その次はベッド基礎疾患がある人それから
だんだん現役のば回かたぶんそのということになって
おそらく8月のどこかには
始められるんです
いいかなと思う
[音楽]
そのタイミングで僕は家に行くのがハイあの
接種券が送られてくるのでなのだろう家の下落をして日本人全員が終わるのが多分10
月から10%家で
そこまでには間違えたと思う
に帰っている
あっ廃校の大臣は youtube 見られますか
見えますおおーーどんな残業のものを
版
それこそ大谷翔平のホームランから
ん
始め消去また見たことあったかな
ちょっと今すぐには思い出せない第二頭でワクチンを打ったらどれくらいかカーなく
なるんですかもうマスク外していいくらい
8すぐマスクが外せるかというとそんなことはないと思っ
ください学振を2回打ってみたい女打ってから3週間経つと免疫が古門し始めるって
なるほどなるほど
2回打って2週間たったらかなり7
守られてると思う
いってもいいと思う
スコーカーが有効率95%でそれはすごい
あの相当めちゃくちゃ強いじゃないですか
いつものインフルエンザの学習によりも
そういうがそれは菅なかった者数若い人にぜひ
打ってもらいたい
色んな国の様子を見てると多分発症しないとか重症化しないだけじゃなくて罰金打っ
たら多分
感染しないということも言えるんだと思う
だんだんこういろんな研究を見ると感染しないって言えるんじゃないっていうところ
まで来ているのでもうそうするとまず自分がかからないし
文がその症状が出なくてもかかっていると人に落ちしてるんですよね
だけど自分がかからなくなるとそういうことで一人移すことのないので周りの人も守っ
ていうことになるかな
右側はぜひ若いしても持ってもらいたいと思います
のことですね
に効果があると廃校の大ジンガー
考えるんですけど
てボーロコロナは様にされです
日本はいっ
那須11月にワクチンを打ち終わるとだいぶ状況は改善する
だと思います
日本だけが打ち終わってもやっぱり大黒と人が行き来をすると
持ってきちゃう始めることがあるのでこの世界中の人のかなりの割合にワクチンを
やっぱり打たないと心がをことに押さえつけたということにはならないと思う綺麗来年
のどっかでそれなりの数を
ワクチンが世界中で打てると少しコーナーが襲ってくる
これ今のところ陛下部全部にワクチンは効果が
あーだけど国家が出ない理由品格が出ちゃうと大変だから
早く売って
客が浮沈を押さえつけて名義が出ないようにする
を砕いた[ __ ]舌てるってことで判別せるだいたい6週間で1回かるって言われるん
です
くっこえーバイトシフト今日みたいな
2週間で1回変化して全く何も変わらないこともあれば感染力が弱くなることもあれば
強くなることも
何が出てくるかわからないから
に早く
て家っていうのがあって
なんか品ネットを見てて僕はすごい不安になったのが
副反応がどうこうっていう傷がすごいあっ
強かったでしょワクチンはこの頃のワクチンに限らず
まあ必ず副反応があると思ってもらっていいと思うんだよね
このウイルスのワクチンはインフルエンザのワクチンよりも副反応が強く出っていうの
は事実ですって例えば僕は8今週の月曜日の朝
打った
んですけどね大臣が自らはい痛かったですおっしゃっいやあのねぇ
針細くて大刺さったチクってきたのはわかったけどもうその後は全然痛くなかったぱそ
そうなんですねただ朝9時に打って夕方の4時頃はもうこの辺まで腕あげるといて
0円寺でこのタンパクとした後じゃな
もう相当運動したらの
30時間後はもう触れこうやって全然問題なかった
1日ながらちょいたった1日経つとあのだいたい副反応はなくなりますで1回目落ちと
多分腕が痛いという人は8割加える9割2回目を打ちとたぶん3人に1人ぐらいは30
匹同5分から38度の熱が出たり桜となくワクチングって誰になって言う
昇祐副反応がやっぱり次の姫ちんちだけど打って2日経つともう
ほとんどの人は回復するっていう感じなのでなるほどあのその程度の副反応はあります
けれども
まああの例えば野球できるかというと腕帯から高パッと思いっきり振れないとか
外科の先生は手術の前の日は
腕痛くなるから手術の前の日やワクチン接種は8
ないとかそういうことはあるけども
日常生活に不便はないですの腕が痛いからといってもここまでは上がるから
なるほどです熱が出てきついなと思ったら解熱剤を飲んでもらえばいいし
痛み止めを飲んでも構わないんで2回目靴
次の日はちょっとのんびりできる日程にしてもらってなんか激しい運動をしようとかっ
ていう予定を立てないで置いておいてくれれば特に問題はない
そんなに怖がる服半ごろでは決してないし効果が非常にある
楽チンなのでそこはぜひ打ってもらいたい
なんかある程度のやっぱ予防接種とか
ワクチンてリスクがあるのかな
誘致をしてましたアナフィラキシーっていう抗アレルギーが急に発症するようなことが
100万人2弾人っていう感じで起きるんだけども
日本でもアナフィラキシーが起きているケースがありますけれども
もうそこがお医者さんがちゃんと見ててくれるんで
全員治療して回復してますからアメリカで2億回ぐらいコロナウイルスのワクチンって
売ってるんですけどもよく買いに置くかえぐってワクチンで死んでる人は一人もいない
a も断言しているそんなに心配することではない
なんかネットの傷るワクチンで死亡みたいな傷とかもあるんですけどちょうどタブ教皇
の大臣が爆沈のデマについてのブログ書かれてるよと思うんです
高齢者の走行な数打っているとワクチンを打って例えば交通事故で亡くなるって言う人
もいるだろうし
ワクチンを打って他のことが原因ではなくなることも
いらっしゃいますけれどもそれは別にワクチンを打たなくても
そういうことで亡くなる人はいるんです
一定の病気だったり例えばくもまっか出血で亡くなったりが口中を売った人と売って
ない人とそこに明確な差があるかというと今のところそんな
フェイスはないよね
なのでよくあるでまでワクチンを打った
実験用のマウスが2年以内に皆死んだ
ありましたはだけでございましただいたい10件ロマンスの寿命って2年だからああ
バク宙を打って人間が100年でみんな診断って言ってるのとほぼ同じような話
それ聞いて釣りですねーずるーデマを流す人はいるんです
は苦心のデマを流す人ってだいたい4つのタイプに分かれて綱
自分の書いた本を読ませたりとかね許せねぇ
自分がやっているその自然治療法みたいなものに引き寄せたいっていうお金が目当て
それから自分のイデオロギーでもう自分のイデオロギーでワクチンは船
んだってもう科学なんか関係ないん移動ルギーでワクチンや部ないと言ってる人箱に
ワクチンが危ないと言っちゃったんで今される立場を変えられないからは口に危ないと
言い続けなきゃいけないっていうのは千葉を守ってる人とあろう
私が来ないぞということで
僕を見てっていう自己承認自己承認力の塊みたいな広くだいたいこの4つのタイプ
若い人はそのネットとか sns とかあるいはユーチューブみたいなものから情報を
もらう人が多いと思うんですけれどもこれはアメリカの研究で twitter とか
facebook に流れているワーク
死んで間の代替65%は12人の人が始めた魔獣3-1と団体が
始めたでそれがどんどん拡散されるんだけど
調べて言ったらこの子の12人がその場ワクチンでは始めたのも皆が拡散してって
世の中に広まった
それを一つずつ手間ですよと言ってやっぱり潰していくということをやって
本当に効果のあるワクチンを若い人にも打ってもらいたいな
うーん
なんかすごい直接国府台前からお聞きできたのですごい安心しましたよ
ございますこの間お忙しいなかお時間をいただきありがとうございますありがとう
ございました
まずはすいませんもうないけど今日の大臣の話を聞いてると
[音楽]
ブーブーエロ
ana
[音楽]